born just three days earlier baby Mamet
starts her life made all the harder by
the earthquakes
his family like many small-scale Turkish
farmers who produced just enough to get
by have lost what little they had
to recover
everything was destroyed I don't know
when we will be back to normal
a few kilometers down the road nessim
Koch is one of this Region's bigger
farmers
the road leading to his farm like the
buildings that once stood here ripped
apart by the shifting ground Nasim has
just been explaining that the ground
where we're standing here is a couple of
meters below the ground just here which
in turn is several meters below the
ground way out just underneath that Barn
there but at one point before the Quakes
happened all of this was on the same
level
his brother who was in The Farmhouse at
the time shows the destruction he found
when he escaped outside with his family
this Farm provided a livelihood for
nessim's extended family of 25 but also
crops and livestock for local markets
what happens if everyone leaves their
lands this earthquake didn't only happen
here but in 10 other provinces if you
stop producing food we would be
dependent upon other countries in the
days and weeks after the earthquakes the
focus has been on saving lives and
providing for the survivors but there's
a growing awareness of the damage to the
agricultural facilities in this
important farming region that threatens
the longer term supply of food early
morning at the Adena wholesale Market
the arrival of produce from surrounding
Farms shows just how abundant this
entire area is together the 11 affected
provinces Supply around a fifth of
national agricultural output and in some
categories they dominate with the
majority of citrus fruit produced here
about three-quarters of the country's
cotton and nearly all of its pistachio
nuts
contributing to Turkey A's exports
Farmers already had problems finding
enough seasonal workers but the Quakes
mean they would have around a third
fewer than they need this year
for the past three years we have
struggled now many migrants have gone
back to Syria we need more workers
this disaster's timing could not have
been worse it seems for the Region's
farmers
coming in Winter which adds to the
misery of homelessness and right before
the spring start of the Agricultural
calendar that is now seriously disrupted
Rob McBride Al Jazeera hatai